o lado sexual de quem fala é o dar que
seja muito bem vindo já mais um vídeo
e/ou mostrado de que sua lenda que um
jogo que já não estragar muito tempo seu
agora ex líder novo que é o dark night e
vou experimentar o jogo é feito em
browser e o meu fred está a dar muito já
capital por isso eu ficar sem viu a maio
não se preocupem porque vai voltar
porque depois volta a gravar e i'll be
café atenção o jogo contém sustos e
imagens de horror e dando é saber
promover e e apanhar 67 país é esse é o
típico flanders só que em vez de ser 88
páginas são sites não sei porque este
tipo está tudo ligado aqui na minha tela
porque eu não consegui ver em fullscreen
não vejo tipo e se encontram em que
envolve quando você tem um tamagotchi e
cravando esqueçam conheçamos é e porque
a minha lanterna parece aquelas coisas
pois mangaraí eu falei que elas coisas
pois magali só não sei qual é o nome
daqui mas parece mesmo e vamos lá andar
porque nós não podemos ficar parados por
que não vender é anjo não consegui
apanhar a página e agora não f não é
pagar a luz e não consegui apanhar aqui
página carnell é fácil apanhar tocar e
sua lei pobre não é visto que é pobre
porque nem escreveu à caneta e escreveu
a lápis é porque esquenta estão caras
estão o que estão um bidon comgás e
porque parece que estou num espaço em
vez de estar numa floresta porque
parecem estrelas e planetas à minha
volta e tá tudo escuro também que o
espaço não tem árvores mais prontas
também não parecem árvores expressa em
cubos falha pronto a falar no encontro
da próxima maior está muito estranho
mesmo eu tô pra ver como é que tá foi do
flamengo e que espero que não seja um
modelo normal deu e ela já estamos
habituados a ver mas eu quero páginas
antes de parceiros laender eu quero
páginas houve alguma coisa a alguém que
o xingou fortaleço hidromel reforço pode
ajudar qualquer pedra não chove no mapa
isso isso não é suposto acontecer
anda lá nós temos que andar aqui à volta
e eu não consigo correr porque o chico
funcionamento deste órgão
o chip não funciona lá corre
corre mais uma copa que em cima da cama
de gato quinto aqui os afagos em
garrafas mil vai atrás nem carros senão
a chance histórica de perto a primeira
cara eu não consegui ver a cara do meu
cabelo é preta e estudar o contrário
está o contrário a cabeça de ouvir se
preta e externas tinham sido não é
cabeça de alves e branca e externas
deviam ser pretas é isso mas não fizeram
dela o contrário não é que isto um tubo
vou entrar aqui só vou entrar aqui vou
entrar aqui porque os vender para trás o
cristo rei vai cantar mion que está a
cantar meu há alguém cantar
isso indica uma queda contínua continua
continua continua a dar continuidades
primeiro teste e meu deus
já saiu já saíu um pinguinho um
pinguinho de coco verde na minha que eu
sentia o cheiro sentido de evitar que
uma página é andar que anda anda apanha
página lá toca nela isso muito bem dark
rock moderno é igual à minha
eu estou sem comer por trás não eu tá em
acabar lá mas ao contrário ou seja a
criação de que só vamos embora vamos
focar para trás mas os câmeras aqui a
minha senhora da guia eu subi a
consultoria duas páginas que só assim
essa imagem também hd e meu futuro está
assustado o esta imagem
ok só dispomos aqui e agora estamos a
jogar no dia ouvir os passarinhos e
agora já não parecem culpa parcial fácil
está tudo muito bonito agora a minha
vida vai voltar a cantar ainda vai
voltar a cantar
é verdade sim senhora ok ok eu estava
preparado possuía que enfrenta uma
paragem de uma primorosa calma
não estou agora meu ok ok agora já não
há sustos
não sei porque não apareceu mas pronto
ainda vai entender melhor o que vamos
acompanhar esta página e passar o que é
isso mesmo só é isso mesmo as páginas
estão sempre no mesmo sítio bem que esta
que estava do lado e acatava ali à
frente mas pronto e agora nós vamos
apanhar a página que está algures é que
numa área franco foi que eu apanhei há
pouco kalil mandatário mas sabe que é
tudo quieto que é do juiz ter uma arma
de andar com o chip no corte concorre
eu só anda eu só ando é tão podre que só
anda e páginas de que nada pois não nova
página aqui em cima muito obrigado muito
obrigado dinho não está aqui uma tac uma
parte do texto que não quis eu sabia ou
não topa tudo ok faz a tua vida meu novo
agora é isso aí nós vamos ficar porque
com estes lenda espero que tenham
gostado e este sim é oficialmente o
clemer dos pobres porque está muito bem
feito é tão especial quanto com o vosso
apoio com esta música aqui foi um time
num leque favorito fiquem bem e até a
próxima
[Música]